okay so hello everyone good evening I'm
max here I'm the chief scientist at
basic technology and just a few words
about basis we're based in in Cambridge
MA and the few of us are based here
right across the street and we build
technologies tools for processing human
languages and different capabilities and
in different languages and specifically
I will talk about named entity
recognition which is about finding names
of people organizations locations and
some other related types in running text
completely unstructured written in
different languages so we work in a
highly
multilingual environment so here is an
example
according to alone mask Mars rocket will
fly short flights next year I don't know
if it's true but definitely Elon Musk is
a person and Mars is a location and next
year is a date entity so we have like a
few entities here and this is the kind
of the results that we expect to see
from a named entity recognizer given
this text now maybe some of you will
think that it could be a simple task
maybe we could just compiled a list of
location names from Wikipedia of
something and then use a very simple
lookup procedure to find all instances
of that list in the text and that's it
maybe but you wouldn't know whether Mars
is mentioned as the location right or
the candy bear so we kind of really need
the context to help us resolve these
kind of ambiguities we don't know that
it's actually a location
okay so context is important so this is
just a fun exercise yes
the name right but another location so
and and it's a good point though our
recognizer will identify the entities
and will tell us the type of the entity
too so we'll say that it's a location
like highlighted in red there or a
person entity or candy bar as your life
so a product that's it cool so yeah it's
location because they speaking about it
not so good not about you're not start
with planet yeah you could you could say
that it really depends on how you decide
to you know how to watch your guidelines
in annotating text you could say that
it's actually the rocket and not Mart so
there is this is another challenge that
we have we named entity recognition so
how you actually what's your guidelines
when you do the annotations and decide
what is an entity and what's not you can
decide that it's a location and anything
related to the location you're not you
don't care about like Rockettes you care
about locations and then you can use
that somehow I really depends but that
was just an example right so this is
just a fun exercise I don't know if
familiar with it but you know to anyone
here who don't so just it's for you
so it's the checker shadow illusion and
this is to show you that context is
important sometimes look at the square
is represented by a and B and tried to
confirm that they actually have the same
background color do you know this food
who saw this before about half okay so
it's actually the same color and
probably people who don't know this will
think that B is actually lighter than a
but it gets darker by the shadow that is
rocked by the green element and it's the
context surrounding B that makes us
believe you know that B is the light box
within this board so therefore it has to
be you know lighter than a but you can
cover everything else in you
immediately if you don't believe me okay
so it's also important context also
important for you know for human
languages so check out this sentence
can't play Spain improve your playing
via a step by step video lessons so
Spain here is not a name of a country
it's a it's just found out written by
you Chick Corea
so it's not the name of a location so it
is an entity but again not a location so
that's the problem we're dealing with
okay so in order to capture the context
we use machine learning and this is why
we're here and we'll talk about it and
and we handle this problem as a sequence
labeling problem means that we process
word by word and for every word we
predict a single label now remember that
you know names may span across multiple
words like Tel Aviv or New York right so
we have different you know positional
labels for for every entity type like be
fair I fair so be fair will be the first
word of a named entity person type and
then I pair would be the second word and
on there similarly below I lock and so
on ad there will be four words that are
not part of a named entity so you can
see here an example I'm working for
basis technology I'm working for all the
four words are all right they're not
names and then basis technologies and
organization so be August beginning and
so on so it's really like sequence
labeling where the inputs are words this
is how we treated and this is the way
that we usually see the annotations this
is how we require the annotation to look
like in a training set where we want to
use it for for doing training we call
those Ohio be right inside outside
beginning annotation okay so we wanna do
machine learning now so let's briefly
discuss the difference between a
traditional machine and and what we're
doing a basis for many years and what we
started to do recently deep learning and
this is specifically for for NLP and
the difference here is in our own
perspective so for example by the way
this is the example that you see here is
not named entity recognition but it
doesn't really matter it's a different
NLP task this is sentiment analysis but
it doesn't matter I mean the input is
the text and the output is a label or
collectable labels it doesn't really
matter now with a traditional machine
learning algorithm the input is the text
and then the first step will be feature
extraction or feature engineering right
where we actually try to extract
features from the input in NLP we
typically start by breaking the text
into words now breaking text into
English words it's pretty simple but
Chinese for example right so you don't
have spaces between words yeah Panisse
Korean all these languages are pretty
difficult more challenging and you need
to use specific tools language specific
tools that by themselves are built our
machine learning models once you extract
words you can extract more linguistic
features that part of speech start with
you like lemmas those are base form of
words without all the practices of it
says I can Hebrew write it very
effective or highly inflected language
like Hebrew and Arabic
for example Spanish and more features
won't discuss all the different types
but once we extract all these features
we can use them and put them together
into a mathematical representation like
a vector and then use that as an input
for traditional machine learning like
anything that you're familiar with you
know for building the model like a
planning procedure build a model and
then use the stammer presentation to do
the prediction with deep learning
approach there is no feature extraction
really right we go directly from text to
the mathematical representation and we
use embeddings to do that are there
different types of embeddings like we
have that so static word embeddings we
have all these contextual embedding
devices and I won't I won't talk about
these in this talk about to say a few
words about you know static embeddings
in the next sliders to give you the
context but those are just picked sized
vectors
and we use them as you know we plug them
in into the deep learning model that we
use it's basically a deep neural net
with many layers and different
configurations architecture or whatever
you want to use right there and that's
it so I would say that I mean if I'm if
I'm using the traditional machine
learning she's focused mostly on the
part where I do feature extraction and
again if I'm I need to support 22 or 23
languages which this is the number of
languages that we support so it's a lot
of work it's very complicated to build
all these tools like lemma ties are for
different languages and on the other
hand with deep learning I will focus
mostly on configuring and designing the
network and I mean if it works for
English it were it may work just as good
for other languages not always with some
tweaks but generally speaking it does so
in that sense deep learning is the more
it's a much more generic approach for
NLP and for us it's it's good news so
just you know to touch based on the
board embeddings part to the people who
are not familiar with this so those are
fixed sized vectors that you can train
ahead of time if you like right and
intuition how you build it is that I
mean when you build it you have like if
you have two similar words in there
meaning like a car in a truck let's say
so they're corresponding vectors will be
similar to right in the sense of cosine
similarity or any other mathematical
distance function so you can and then
you can do things like that you can take
the vector Japan subtract the vector of
Tokyo if you like this is like an
element-wise linear operation and then
add the vector of berlin it's another
vector you get a new vector and so you
took the country remove the capital city
add another capital city and then you
get a new vector which is not part of
your vocabulary but it will be very
similar to the vector of germany in your
vocabulary and that's pretty cool and
this is the kind of calculations that
happen inside on your net right
you insert vectors and then there are
some you know different gates and
operators that take place and calculate
all these things like linear operations
as well as nonlinear operations and at
the end you get a result and you train
all this all together all right so a
simple feed-forward Network for named
entity recognition looks something like
that
very simple and I'm I do assume some
background but I'll go over this so we
said that we process word by word for
example we want to predict the label for
the word Spain right here in blue so
what we do we want to predict the label
will text its vector right here that's
the vector of Spain and in order to
capture the contact with a feed-forward
Network we simply capture the context by
considering like let's say the vector
two words before in to our doctor that's
it okay or three it's a fixed size
window right the surrounding context so
you take all these vectors put them one
next to each other or concatenate them
right so you get a long vector you use
it as an input for a feed-forward neural
net with many layers as many of you want
and the output layer will have to be of
the size of the number of labels that
you have in your in your data set so if
you're only care about people
organizations locations at PLO so you
have about seven different labels right
two for each and one for other and it
works surprisingly well okay but you can
do better than that
and you see no feature engineering
nothing you do need to break the text
into words right that's one thing and
then you need to have some you know
embedding library that you can use and
it works but the limitation here
obviously is is what what do you think
the limitation is
huh label data is always a limitation
yeah but in terms of space their model
so it's about the context we only
capture like towards before towards up
there what is the evidence world worth
to be detected as a name is not here if
somewhere else in the sentence right so
in order to capture that we may use a
recurrent neural network which is better
for this kind of cases or rnm and that's
a vanilla RNN so here we take the vector
stain we send it directly to the first
layer here and then instead of taking
the vector of the you know the immediate
context what we do is this we take the
output from this layer from the first
layer after it's got modified with all
the weights and everything that we
learned during back propagation we take
this output vector and we push it again
into like it's a feedback loop so we
push it again into the that layer but
concatenated with the vector of the
following word meaning when we want to
predict the label for stain we send its
own vector and the output vector from
the previous word that's what's
happening here and then the same output
vector goes into the final layer of the
network for doing the prediction by the
way that final layer is typically using
soft map just to calculate the
distribution across all the labels in
the output so and you can actually
visualize this way some people will find
it better to look at this this way we
just unfolded the network right and you
can see at time T right there so we take
the word at time P like the position T
in the sentence after we break the text
into a list of of words we take the
vector of the word T we send it into the
layer and the the first layer the fully
connected layer together what you see
right here that's the output layer they
store the output vector from the
previous time step and then the output
vector will go into prediction and also
to the following layer I mean the same
layer but for the following word so you
see that information flows from the
beginning of the sentence
throughout the entire sentence and every
word in its turn can benefit from all
that information so all the context from
by the beginning of sentence is flowing
and every word can benefit and also can
contribute more information to that
vector so this sector gets modified all
the time every time it passes word gates
now it turns out that it remembers too
much information and it gets overwhelmed
pretty quickly with the large amount of
information it needs to store we
mathematically we call this a gradient a
vanishing gradient problem exploding
gradient problems we won't get into that
but intuitively there's two motive or
information sometimes we need to forget
some of that information and be able to
make room for more information to be
stored so there is a nice flavor
specific flavor of RNN called long
short-term memory
lsdm very popular and go-to technology
for doing some sequence labeling and
instead of using a single pulley
connected layer here we use like a more
complicated node with a few more layers
inside I won't go into all the details
but you can get all this information
online pretty quickly it's very popular
well what happens here is the same
information flows from the beginning of
the sentence and and here is just every
time the vector crosses this node it can
also lose some of the information to
make room for more important information
to be captured okay so this is the
picture of cloaks right so the words get
in to the network but sometimes the
information comes from their right-hand
side all right so here let's say here
Chicago I can only benefit from
information that comes from the
beginning of sentence but not from the
other side so we typically use another
another such process lsdm process we
call this bi-directional lsdm and those
are two independent processes and then
typically we have like two vectors that
one goes from here and one goes from
here to output vectors we concatenate
them and use that double size vector
as an input for the final layer for
doing the prediction similar as what we
did before let me give you a few more
tips of how you can extend this you can
maybe extend it with another layer of
lsdm of bi-directional at the end if you
like or another one if you like so you
get more more parameters as many as you
like and obviously that will be a huge
monster and it will take time to Train
and it will take also time to predict
and if you can you take a risk of our
fitting for sure so you need to take
some measures here to avoid overfitting
and one last go I have two more
suggestions one is instead of using the
simple softmax prediction or decody use
something else like CRF conditional
random field enhanced version of hmm
because this simple soft much what would
consider the label that was predicted
for the previous world and there are
some rules here right for example a pair
can only happen after be here alright so
and nobody enforce that for now with the
CRA for hmm we can enforce these kind of
things right and I won't go into detail
because we don't have much time but
that's another trick that people do
usually and it works pretty well it adds
a few minor points to the result
according to our tests lusting has a
promise this is their character based
encoding so so far we only encoded women
considered words and information but
there are important information
characters like capital letters right
for English it's very important it's a
good indicator we want to capture that
we want to use that information so we
can use like another lsdm model similar
like this but on the character level and
but here we don't need to do predictions
like we did here so we don't need to use
these output vectors for every character
we can use the output vector from the
last character both sides and use that
representation vector as you know I said
the vector that represents the
information about the character for
every word we can
tonight it with word level vectors that
we have and like these three vectors
together represent a single world and it
works pretty well for different
languages yes limitation
typically we don't do that we will just
go with the raw data and don't do we
don't we're not trying to do any feature
extraction at that point of time because
the system will learn automatically
that's the thing so here are some
results that we tried in our lab so we
trying to train a deep learning model
the same one that you just so with a few
more tweaks maybe four different
languages here I'll show you on the
English Arabic and Korean and we
compared it to a traditional machine
learning model that we are using a basis
for about 15 years or something so you
can see that with no feature extraction
anything like that we were able to
improve results across the board or
languages that's pretty exciting for us
if you want to use the models you can go
to or that developer web commerce it's
the name of our products that's not the
same the company but you could go there
and you can open a free account if you
like and get a free quota and we have
like a cloud service or on-prem and then
you can you know install our set api
package binding for python and then you
can start sending texts and get back the
results it's pretty easy and it works
for 22 languages japanese arabic hebrew
included of course english all the
european young which is a few Asian
languages and so on and the output will
look exactly the same before Matt so
there are a few flags here you can say
that you want to calculate salience I
told you that we have a few more tweaks
so like calculate salience whether the
entity is important in the document or
not so we have a few more models there
we have a linker something that will
link the entity to its potential
identity in a knowledge base if you like
we also use there another model to do
that and here you can decide whether to
use our deep ler
model based on lsdm or the traditional
one which is the default model and then
for example you can run you know this
text and run it through the system and
get these kind of results I could format
JSON I only put your part part of it so
you see that the first one is a node the
first node is an entity and you can see
exactly where it was mentioned in the
document character offset and then you
know the text itself confidence and on
top here entity ID you can see that it
was linked to to a knowledge base
basically we use Wikipedia by default
but you can change that to use your own
knowledge base if you like and this the
type is organization so that's the SEC
if you're familiar with it last thing I
want to cover this sock so it's a little
bit about the lsdm as a black box
because we talked about it before we
said with a traditional machine learning
you create features and then you send
them into a machine learning algorithm
and then you learn something and then
you can sometimes measure how effective
the feature is that you extracted for
you know for the the learning tasks that
you were assigned for here it's a bit
more complicated because we don't have
any features to major right we didn't
create any features but in fact if you
look at the network you can look at it
as if here there is a feature generator
right because a vector will go right
here but two vectors doesn't matter here
it will go here a vector into the final
layer so you can consider this as a
linear classifier with a vector that
goes into the input of that layer so
this is like a vector feature that we're
generated together together with the
learning task or altogether right using
the back propagation so if you look at
this vector specifically it's the same
vector here here it doesn't matter we
will look at this vector and the number
of dimensions in this vector will be as
you know as much as you want this is
like a hyper parameter for the model
right it's like we used typically 500
dimensions we also call them new
right of 500 neurons for example so if
we look at this vector of 500 numbers
that will go through you know with
travel through the sentence the input
sentence and will get modified after
every word we might learn something
maybe now it's going to be a difficult
task but we built this tool so this tool
it's a very simple one that takes a
model that we already trained and you
can write a sentence right there and you
see it was broken into words and then
every words is here and here you see the
label that was predicted for that word
all of the board here we're OHS and
because they are not names right now if
you see and then what you what you see
here so every line here is a single
neurons the activations of that vector
and I hollered here everything so it
will be easy to detect patterns by
eyeballing the the data right so every
number here every vector is a new one
it's a single neuron so if you look at
it for example here there is a pattern
something goes negative the numbers by
the way are between minus 1 and 1
because the output of lsdm activation
vector is just it's just like that it
uses a gate a specific gate that does
that 10h if you're familiar with it ok
so we ran many sentences here and look
them manually to see if we understand
anything 99.9 percent of the time we
didn't understand anything
it's just features that are not
interpretive all for humans at least not
for for me very late at night usually
anyway but if you look at this we found
something
280 the neuron 280 when we send many
sentences throughout this neuron you can
see that it get positive values when it
sees punctuation marks so obviously this
is a feature that they fit them needed
in order to detect entities right so
that's an example just to look inside
what it actually learned and another
example is this one if you like neuron
189 with the every time it sees the word
which I think it's a good indicator for
a location right so it will start to get
negative for few words of time so here
you see I live in New York that's the
input sentence and you see that in urine
gets negative right here and the output
labels were correct so this is a GP but
it's a geopolitical entity its location
organization together right so it was
detected correctly and so it helps
probably for doing the detection I don't
know but here I live in a van it's not a
named entity the system was correctly
labeled those words with O's but still
we got negative values right so the
system can benefit from this feature but
can but it knows to ignore it when it's
necessary the last thing I wanted to
show you here I live in a van and I have
a new guitar so you can see that this
neuron gets negative here and at some
point it's just starting to forget right
and go goes back to that original value
around the zero so that's a property of
lsdm right a property of information
that is stored for some times and then
we know sometimes that we don't need
this information anymore it didn't help
throughout the training process after so
many words like four or five words we
just don't need this information or it
won't help us so we start to forget that
and not to be distracted by this
information and with that I'm done the
questions yes if we should compare the
results we do that sometimes but
remember that comparing is very
difficult because some you know some
different tools different capabilities
sometimes built on different guidelines
we started with this actually it was
yeah it was a good thing to start with
so when it's you know different
guidelines is very difficult to compare
sometimes we do that
label data depends so depends on the
language right and yeah so we do have
partners that we work with and we out so
some of the labeling some we did
ourselves with annotator but mostly wood
you know we were partners but we defined
the guidelines which is probably the
most difficult problem we ever touched
here more than the neural nets okay so
it's very difficult something very
difficult to agree on and make sure that
all your annotators do the same so we
have partners that we you know go a long
way together and we work with them of
transferring from from easier language
soup yeah that's that's a good yes so we
have ideal but we didn't do anything
with that this yeah it's very
interesting like through may be
multilingual embeddings that's
definitely something on their radar but
didn't do anything
yeah thanks so much again
[Applause]